pensez l'espoir a beaucoup enfin moi je
trouve un soin qui serait bien c'est que
par exemple je paye des impôts comme
tout le monde qu'il ya un genre de
l'auto aux impôts si vous voulez que
l'on paie nos impôts quitte à payer plus
mais qu'il ya quelques uns qui soient
tirés au sort et puis qu'il payerait
puis la peau ou même quand les
remboursements je voudrais qu'ils qui
pleuvent la nuit puisque il faut et le
jour qui fasse beau temps quoi pourquoi
parce que là la nuit pour qu'il pleuve
ce serait bien pour les agriculteurs
puis le jour ce serait bien pour les
vacances hic c'est que parti quoi on ne
pousse pas christine ont créé voilà qui
dans un cri comment s'appelle christine
[Musique]
ockrent qui ne les pousse pas ce n'est
pas une fille pour lui parce qu'il
devait pas s'il devait se marier d'après
la presse franchement j'aimerais bien
que l'on trouve un inventeur qui a vanté
ses grâces
qui
quelque chose qui nettoie les glaces 106
grâce pour embêter les contractuels j'en
ai ras-le-bol des pv votre souhait pour
84 mademoiselle ce beau toute l'année
surtout tous les mois est beaucoup plus
chaud qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi et bien
comme ça on pourrait porter la minijupe
toute l'année sans se mouiller sans
mourir de froid
c'est beaucoup plus agréable pour les
commerçants du quartier
je pense qu'il faudrait que leur revers
soit plus blanc rouge comme ça on
pourrait prendre nous les décisions
c'est sympathique non bah tu vois je
voudrais plus de noël dans le nez parce
que parce qu'il ya passé parce qu'il
n'ya pas cette cadeaux on voudrait
combien
ont fait une dizaine votre souhait pour
84 à vous je souhaiterais ça serait un
beau mariage avec jacky alex ardents ça
me plairait énormément même si ce n'est
que du jour bien revoir un petit peu la
mode revenir un peu sur les bas noirs
les petites coutures foncé sur des puits
des jupes raccourcies un petit peu avec
une petite fente sympathique
entrevoir les genoux
[Musique]
pour 84 votre souhait rencontré le
prince charmant
je voudrais que les grandes personnes
soyez moins méchant surtout les chefs
d'état parce qu'ils puissent on ou plus
ils font la guerre pour 84 je voudrais
des patins à roulettes pour quoi faire
mais pour quoi faire pour pouvoir
patiner
[Musique]